[Music]
good to see you yeah good to see you
ever coming out we're doing a
doubleheader today
oh you are I was joking with Colin that
you guys brought the Oregon weather to
Oregon triathletes on the same day yeah
it's crazy yeah and we did the rain is
is pretty bad out there right now but
still pretty still nicer than we as we
were talking still a lot nice and Bend
is right now
you had like 11 degrees yeah yeah so I
got a run outside today for the first
time in two weeks which even though it
was downpour you know thunderous
downpour the entire run it was a lot
nicer than running on the treadmill why
do all these professional triathletes
live in places with inhabitable weather
I don't understand you know that's a
good question
it's nice a lot of the year but yeah it
is it can be a drag you get you know I
discovered Nordic skiing Nordic skiing
super fun it's a nice way to spend the
winter and then you and then you kind of
forced to change it up a little bit
which is nice you know I think if I if I
could actually swim bike and run all
year outside I would be much more likely
to hurt myself probably I got through or
burn out you hear these stories of guys
that that like move to Hawaii for that
reason right and then and then nothing
happened you think like oh that'll be
like this Archimedes lover that's
Yannick their career yeah fantastic but
it never ends up that way yeah and
ultimately you just got to be where you
want to be you know I mean for me Bend
is home and that's it's fan right yeah
and that's like that just trumps
everything else you know and it's not
all about triathlon either I mean right
you know it's like where did where does
it make sense for my family to be and
and word I want to be long-term as I
pivot away from it as well you know
sorry yeah well you're in a really
interesting moment in your career yeah
which i think is super interesting to
explore I mean we we we've only met once
it was super briefly it was out on the
bike yeah right it is they're trying to
figure out when that was it was like
yeah 2013 yeah I remember that uh what I
here's what I remember okay yeah please
I remember I was riding by myself and I
was riding up rocks tour yep which is
just down the way here it's like one of
the you know more well thing
on it climbs and I'm just doing my thing
and then suddenly this freight train 20
people just passes me like I'm standing
still and I'm like [ __ ] what's going
on here and I realized it was Matt
Dickson's got a purple patch fitness
yeah camp and then you guys were just
gone and then later on in the ride I was
like down in West Lake or whatever and I
spied I spied you and I think you were
riding with Luke Bella Bella yeah yeah
caught up to you guys and we child yeah
I remember that I remember specifically
because I had seen you we had mutual
friends
I think bit or a kind of through
Stanford started swimming and so I knew
of you had you know heard of your book I
think at that point I can't remember
exactly what what had or had not been
published by that time but um so I
recognized you when we I think we knew
even when we first went by and I was
like I think that that was rich Rome but
I didn't know for sure and then when we
saw you
it's pretty crazy actually that we saw
you again yeah her on on that because it
was hours later right it was hours later
and I would have figured you got you
might have taken a different route I
don't know how and you weren't with the
rest of the group at that point no we
had split I remember actually very
specifically because that ride was the
ride that Luke Belle and I just pretty
much like pummeled each other on the
next climb after we like on the way back
from the from the ocean right I can't
remember what climb it was but I just
remember I was super psyched because I
was riding next to Luke Belle was which
was basically it and I knew he was
working hard and I was working hard it
was and for me as like a young you know
first or second year professional
triathlete that was like a highlight
training moment from all that I was so
strong with Luke Belle yeah exactly
small small world yeah yeah and since
that moment I mean you've gone on you've
made a you know huge impression on the
sport which I want to talk about but
before we even track it back like let's
talk about what's going on right now
because you're at this interesting
intersection between professional
athlete life and you know not retirement
but at different gaze of what that looks
like for you as you know parents as a
house
as a business owner and as an athlete
yeah I think you know after eight years
of you know pedal to the metal
athletic pursuit while still doing those
things that you just mentioned as well I
mean I got married right before I
started racing triathlons so I was
married and then about four years five
years into it we had our first kid the
whole time we've had a business that was
going on as a side project but really
had taken on a life of its own so this
last eight years it's been I've been
doing the business and the family thing
under to a certain extent under families
always kind of top priority but you know
what it's like it's under the context of
I'm trying to be a world-class
professional triathlete and that's like
the when I wake up that's the main goal
of the day is world-class professional
triathlete and then I'll do the other
stuff as best as I can to in that day
and I think after the last after feeling
a couple things feeling like I had
accomplished a lot of what I wanted to
accomplish in the sport you know won
some Iron Man's and done you know raced
fast it raced it at a really high level
and felt like I had garnered the respect
of a lot of the guys which foot which
meant a lot to me and then feeling like
I really pulled towards the problems in
the the interesting like challenges of
the business more so than like trying to
win another race you know like all of a
sudden there's like these challenges
that are kind of you're like more
interested in them and then but most
importantly it was a family piece it's
like man dude my son who's five now
he'll be six in a couple months I mean
his dad was like a grandpa you know
that's that's how I that's how I talked
about it to people because that whole
time I was in the peak of my career and
when I came home every day I was just
smoked so it was like less time and the
time is worse that you're spending with
them and I just was like I just don't
want to do that any
like I want to be able to go he's now
capable of doing things I want to go do
those things with them and enjoy it with
him so it's a combination of those three
things that I've you know feel like I'm
starting to just pivot pivot away from
this being a world-class professional
triathlete and I don't really like the
word retirement but like you know I'm
gonna the focus is different right you
know it's a it's a different phase
exactly yeah so a typical day in the
life of a professional triathlete I mean
you're trained in twenty five thirty
hours a week I would imagine yeah what I
think like in the early years I was and
then as the business and family thing
came on it was more like 15 for me which
is like you just said probably about
half of what a lot of the guys that I
was racing against rats that's a lot
lower than a lot lower yeah I mean you
know I probably hit 20 a couple times in
the bit in the big weeks but you know
but yeah I mean it regardless even if
it's 20 hours or 15 hours it's a lot of
time and that's as we were talking about
earlier that's not that doesn't include
the extra time you need to sleep and all
your physical therapy and all the to and
from and everything so it's a lot and
the lack of energy that you have yeah
you know cuz you're just exhausted yeah
exactly
but but what is unique about you is that
you started this business picki bars
when did you guys originate this it was
2010 2002 yes about eight years right
years ago and so as you make this Segway
you actually have this like thriving
ongoing concern you know what it is it's
like you I mean I think it's super
important I think it's super impressive
for anybody to launch a business and
make it successful you know I know a
little bit about the food industry like
I know how difficult it is it's crazy
you're entering a market where there's a
million competitors like there's a
million reasons why you know this thing
would have failed right out of the gate
and you've made it successful well
you're also this last professional
triathlete Thanks you know but now that
you have the energy and the bandwidth to
you know shift your focus you have
something to be you know the receptacle
of that passion and that
energy and when I kind of canvass not
just triathlon but a lot of you know
world-class athletes across the board
especially in sports where you know the
it's not a financial thing like yeah
making it so naman yeah but it's so
all-consuming and then they they hit
that retirement point and they're like
well I don't know what to do you know I
do now I'd never thought about it
because my whole life in focus was about
being the best athlete that I thought I
could possible yeah it's hard and I wish
you know it'd be nice if I could say
that yeah that was all part of my grand
plan you know but it's kind of just
something that happened and I feel and
I'm very lucky and fortunate that it's
that I do have this path this really
obvious not only like just an obvious
job but like something that I'm
legitimately passionate about and
interested in that is kind of the
coolest part of it because I think you
can go get a job and you can do it you
could find a way to make a living but as
you know from your you know from I mean
from your life you know it so much of
life's fulfillment is about pursuing
things that you're passionate about and
that you're interested in and that's the
thing that maybe I feel most excited
about is that regardless of how big or
successful or whatever it becomes in
those terms it's interesting to me and
and it is very lucky I mean I remember
writing I wrote an article about it for
triathlete magazine like four or five
years ago when I was kind of halfway
through my career and I'd been in the
career long in my career long enough to
have half the guys that I race against
retire and just seeing them seeing the
varying paths and you know quote unquote
success or personal fulfillment or
whatever it is that you're looking at
and making this realization like man how
how do you do this if you've been doing
this for ten to twelve are these guys
longer than I have from a much younger
age it's a hard transition you know you
have a really clear goals really really
clear you know passion and and then all
of a sudden you're like what's next and
yeah it's tough it's like an existential
crisis it is for a lot of people
a lot of people who you know then kind
of struggle you know they end up
partying too much
they end up in you know jobs that they
really like and and you know I think
that not just triathlon but all sports
could do a better job of you know
creating you know organizations or
institutions to help athletes guide them
through that process of transitioning
from full-time athlete into civilian I
agree I mean you know a sport like
triathlon us along you know a long long
way to go before something like that
exists I think but I totally agree I
would hope I would hope some of the
major sports have something like that
you know because those those kids are
even to a certain extent well I guess
maybe better and worse you know maybe
they probably have made a lot more money
so that maybe that maybe it just doesn't
matter they can sit on it I think some
of the NFL have like programs to help
them learn how to manage their money and
all that off but yeah which is different
that most of those careers are way sure
super short and they're so young when
they're done yeah yeah well one of the
things that you've talked about or
written about and have opinions on is
like the unionization of athletes and oh
yeah in triathlon yeah
which seems to me like a no-brainer and
a long-overdue idea especially when the
sport is so tiered that you know there's
a very very tiny percentage of people at
the very top who are doing very well
yeah but you know just Pope just beneath
the surface there and it's like a real
struggler there's anybody beneath that
like I don't know how they survive at
all yeah the stats the the stats I've
written articles or an article or two
about this to the you know the when I
kind of pulled when I had been in the
sport long enough to know all the guys
you know at least all the men and a lot
of the women in the sport it was like
hey if you look at kkona kkona is
getting you know 40-ish women and fifty
to sixty guys and there's ten of those
on each side that are making pretty good
money more so on the men's side on the
women's side it's you could take all
these numbers and probably divide it by
half
yeah exactly and then there's so there's
this kind of top ten threshold then
there's like another 15 that are making
a decent you know like a living and then
after that the whole second half of even
the Kona field is probably subsidizing
money from a significant other or a
government thing or they or they're
coaching on the side or whatever it is
and so it's really really steep and
that's that's like the top 50 60 men in
the world and right for women it's even
worse these are the best
yeah Ironman distance athletes exactly
and the sports so expensive there's so
much available to all these fancy places
and there's so much gear and yes I'm
sure you know all those people get their
gear given to them gratis by you know
kind of ambassador deals but there's
this mistaken belief that there's a lot
of money going now is this not the case
so really small it's you know it's an
inherently small sport you know and and
there's more mainstream money and
advertisers coming into it now and I
certainly benefited during my time from
you know the first race that I won in
2011 to last year 2018 a lot of money
coming into the sport and like growth of
the sport and that was you know
beneficial to me from on the sponsorship
side but but yeah it's tough it's tough
to make a living and and I think you
know back to your original question the
the unionization of it it's one of those
things and it's not just triathlon it's
every it's every Olympic type sport
where you have individuals as opposed to
teams and there's and there's no there's
no league that is organizing how that
how those people become Pro like
legitimately Pro and what you end up
having is all these athletes that spend
all their time all their energy all
their money for this these one or two
performances in an Olympic sort of World
Championships or whatever it is and the
sport itself and the governing bodies of
that sport benefit immensely much more
so from those moments than the athletes
typically do themselves of course you
know
unless you're one of the transcendent
athletes that really made it and you're
on a Wheaties box or whatever and you're
you know you're doing it but there's
some that that's so few and beyond that
in triathlon you have an organization
that's profiting wildly off just the
participation yeah you know it's the one
sport where you know the amateur is
competing right alongside the pro and
it's an incredibly what you know the WTC
is sitting upon on top of mountains of
money yeah that could be allocated in a
much more equitable way presumably you
know yeah III it it seems like that you
know it's um I think that until until
professional triathletes make it as
abundantly clear as possible how you you
know stake a claim in terms of how
important or unimportant they are to the
production of the sport into the soul of
the sport it's gonna it's hard for you
know the business the business isn't
gonna react to it any other way then
just do the best that they can for their
for their business yeah and their
responses has sort of historically been
like listen you know our our audience
and our customer bases the amateur not
the pro yeah but you're interchangeable
that's kind of that that seems they're
using the but either using the pros a
lot to help market the sport and you
know like the NBC broadcast is heavily
driven by the Pro Race although they do
in a we've a lotta raishin yet they do
interweave a lot of inspirational
stories in there you know yeah it's it's
an interesting it's an interesting deal
ultimately if you if there's no
organization that exists what if the
pros don't organize themselves then you
have no leverage I mean it's just like a
basic business deal you know and that's
ultimately what it comes to and until
that until that coalesce is it will be
it'll be hard to enact a whole bunch of
change particularly in triathlon where
you do have strip away how fair or
unfair or whatever you think WTC and
Ironman is the fact of it is is that
they hold a monopoly on the sport which
is
it's super unique to triathlon the Mara
that doesn't exist in the marathon it
does exist a little bit in the Olympics
with IOC and USATF so you see a lot of
the same problems but but in triathlon
it's really specific there so are you
optimistic that you think that there
will be some organization here I hope so
there it's one of those things where
it's really tough it's it's um there's
probably an economic way to describe the
problem but the basic problem is the
people that have the most influence have
the least to gain right like just like
we were talking about those guys the
guys at the top they have the least to
gain by unionization of the athletes and
then the set and then the secondary
problem is you have a constantly like
replenishing workforce if you want to
call it that versus the company itself
estatic right WTC is there they have all
they know what they're doing they've got
their [ __ ] together the athletes are new
every three to five years you have this
arc where you don't even know what's
going on then you know what's going on
then like similar to me you're like
right so it's and that happens every
that every wave yeah so I don't know
it'll be interesting to see what happens
with it you know there are some people
that are working on it we we I was part
of a pro triathlon board that ultimately
failed like a lot of boards do because
it was all volunteer led organization
that just couldn't coalesce enough
energy to like organize to make
meaningful change but there's some
people that are there working on it now
so well there was one board at one
moment that was organized around trying
to have more parity in the women's field
at Kona right yeah and I don't know I
that was a movement at least I'm
forgetting the name of it right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
42 Kona right 452 Kohner I can't
remember what but but yeah that um and
you know I don't know what the the
result of that was to be honest is you
know yeah
so let's track it back yeah you start
off as this standout track and field
star steeplechase hardly a star I don't
know man you end up Stanford you set the
school record
yeah that's true I didn't come on I
don't know I guess I was running at that
time at that time Stanford was so good
that the track and field team was so
good that I honestly kind of felt like I
was an underachiever on that on that
team and by most accounts and measures I
probably was so this is the you kind of
came in on the heels of like Ryan and
Sarah Hall right yeah a little bit older
than you right no I was older yeah yeah
so they they were but I I was in between
this window of the like I started in
1998 uh-huh and so in 96 or 97 Stanford
won the cross country national
championships and then we had this run
from like 98 mm Hall through Ryan Hall
2004 2005 where we had lots of national
championships loss of individual
national champions guys going 1 2 3 in
the 10k and you know and then even and
then maybe even more impressive than any
of that is 2 to 4 men making the Olympic
team I mean as collegiates you know and
in various events so it was a crazy
competitive so I mean I want to pac-10
championship you know I rather say that
in C double A's we did pretty good I'm
pretty good very proud of yeah in
Scituate all-american yeah yeah we can
run very proud of but it but it
definitely was like you know second
fiddle for sure to those guys that were
making the Olympic team right so so it
wasn't like okay I'm going for the
Olympics I mean this is gonna be my path
glory I actually thought I did when I
got eight that year I was 22 and then I
had and then I went to USA's and
actually did better I was like eleventh
or twelfth at USA so I was like I was
like the fourth or fifth collegiate guy
and but you're in the game I was in the
game I was like hey if I passed nine
more guys in two years I'm on the
Olympic team and that's that was that
felt possible within the realm of
possibility to me and then but then the
following fall I I got a stress fracture
in my foot
I had a fifth year of eligibility in
cross country and got a stress fracture
in my foot and then
training for trying to cross train I was
riding my bike a whole bunch and I went
over the handlebars of my bike and broke
my neck about like six or eight months
later Wow yeah and so and then that was
that was basically the end at that time
I would kind of like the legitimate end
of my athletic career so yeah and that
was well you were what doing like Coe
term at Stanford yeah I was doing a
Bachelor masters Coe term so I was kind
of finishing up my master's degree and
had started working a little bit with
this with another with a group of guys
that we're gonna start a fuel-cell
company and with but had had literally
just I think a day or two before told
their CEO like hey I'm probably not
gonna do it I think I'm gonna try to
race bikes or do whatever and then I
went over in my handlebars and was like
actually cool I'll be as soon as I'm out
of the hospital come join ya enough of
that one crash and like I'm out looking
and and just to kind of you know paint
the picture of Stanford you know it at
this moment yeah it's you know this is
entrepreneurship central location that
is blowing up everybody's founding
startups yeah and so you're like I'm I'm
I want in on this yeah yeah I think so I
mean for better and for worse you know I
think like I went through I had this
this terrible accident and I went from
kind of being a you know national class
athlete and building a whole bunch of my
identity around an athlete to literally
just not being able to do anything for
months and months and months I was on I
was on my mom's flew home after the
surgery of a week or two after the
surgery and I was on my mom's couch just
24 hours a day and and then and so and
so then I was like what am I gonna do
you know I can't I can't race I'm not it
can't even be physical I may as well try
to you know use my brain right I guess
and be a part of this thing and and
that's what it enough happening right
yeah so you do that for a couple years
like how does that play out yeah we we
were you know like I like to say we were
like a lot of startups
a lot of the startups that you don't
hear about we we raise a lot of money
and made almost none you know yeah no
one tells that story away all our equity
I've got love I've got lots of friends
that went to Stanford that have been
very very successful and I was not one
of those and he's not with that no not
with that and but we it's a great group
of guys I worked really hard and I
basically went that you know maybe maybe
typically I went to the other end of the
spectrum where I was had been I had been
I was serious about being an engineer at
Stanford I mean you have to be to be an
engineer at standard you can't flow
through it but I was also running and
running was the most kind of the most
important thing and when I went when I
didn't have to run or didn't have to do
anything
athletically I I went full gas into that
startup and then for better and for
worse experienced what it was like to be
full-on engineer product developer guy
working 80 to 100 hours a week in San
Francisco in my mid-20s and sleeping at
the office when I could sleep and being
you know treating my body terribly you
know and just kind of seeing that other
end of the spectrum and there are a lot
of there were a lot of great times
during that time too it was just it's
kind of just like this interesting
meandering of you know life and you kind
of test I think ultimately I was kind of
like testing that extreme of the of
myself that extreme side of myself like
if I just work work work all the time
what does that look like what does that
look like yeah what does that feel like
do I feel fulfilled from it you know cuz
there's because I there's still like
this you're striving for a goal right
you've got the big goals it's just not
that let it goes anymore it's like
there's a big business goal but
ultimately that ended up feeling wrong
as well did you have that self-awareness
though that okay I'm testing myself in a
different way now or else yours 22 I was
22 now I'm just like I'm just gonna do
everything full-on in that and you know
that's what you do in your life yeah
yeah yeah triathlon yeah
well if I'm gonna work I'm gonna work
100 hours alright and you know and that
was and that was it and then it was um
you know maybe I guess it's like not
surprisingly like reconnecting with
Lauren my now wife who is my kind of I
like to say on-again off-again but
mostly off-again girlfriend in college
we got in the same class she was one
year younger than me yeah and so we
dated off and on at Stanford you know
the story goes I broke up with her kind
of multiple times for terrible reasons
mostly just but I think actually you
know honestly just feeling insecure
about how successful she was was a big
part of it how successful of a runner
she was so she was she ran 5,000 meters
yeah yeah she was a 5k runner and I mean
you you could basically say the most
successful Stanford you could almost say
the most successful Stanford collegiate
athlete of like any sport almost I think
she won the most the most all-americans
of any sport in Stanford school history
and a bunch of NCAA championships and in
a really nice person you know so said
but I think for me that I think that was
hard seeing her have so much success and
then me feeling like like I described
not like I wasn't really being as
successful as I wanted to be and you
know being very much in love with her
but then also feeling down about myself
because that was who I was comparing
myself to so and at the end when you're
18 19 20 years old that's a really tough
mental check for this kid that comes
from a small town you know ego and and
everything in it you know right and it
you know yeah so so much do you think
like it's interesting do you think like
like were you intimidated by her or do
you feel like there was some
self-sabotage there like I think there
was a little I think there was a little
bit of self sabotage where I think
that's probably a good way to put it I
think I was just becoming trying to
become comfortable with it which and it
sounds so silly now so many years later
but just try
become comfortable with not being the
best at whatever I was trying to do you
know and that was like I said I grew up
in this little in the little town
Central Oregon and been and I was you
know I was lucky I was good at the
number of things that I did and and to
not feel like I used to be in like the
best yeah yeah kind of you know and
that's and it's so silly to think about
that now that that mattered to me so
much at that time but at what but it was
a you know I was young and that was that
was my headspace in the at the time and
and it took me a lot it took me I guess
it took me altum Utley becoming not that
person that I was where I was where so
much of my identity was wrapped around
athletic success or even just success in
general to feel comfortable being with
Lauren because I wasn't comparing my
success or failure to hers right and
then throwing yourself into the startup
culture and yeah I'm like I need to
distinguish myself in this world in the
same way that I did on the track yeah
and then oil to empathy and then
ultimately I guess like through that
kind of bouncing from one extreme to the
other extreme understanding ultimately
that my that my actual own happiness and
fulfillment lies in in the middle and
and that that I do actually I do
actually want to have both of these
things in my life I do want to have a
professional side in an athletic side
and I want to I want to do the best that
I can to balance those two and not feel
like I'm so far into one that I'm
completely neglecting the other and then
that that ultimately set up you know my
path for what I ended up doing in
triathlon and and everything else yeah
so what's interesting kind of being on
the outside looking in on your life
which is you know look through the lens
of what you choose to share on social
media yeah yeah of course right about
but the appearance is of somebody who is
a family guy first who happens to be
this amazing athlete married to another
amazing athlete that's also running this
business it's a complicated equation it
is a lot of moving pieces but there
appears to be
like a healthy sense of balance and
understanding of what's most important
in terms of priorities from the way in
which you kind of share this experience
with it with the world of what it's like
to be involved in all of these different
things and and an attempt to be you know
successful and healthy at the same time
yeah I think that you know that's it's
that's been a long work in progress over
the last let's call it 15 20 years you
know I was it went started Stamford 20
years ago and navigating through these
what you might call success or failure
in in certain areas ultimately to find
out you know hey what what the what do i
what do i altima care about and like
what ultimately makes me happy and then
and like you said it's it's it's
actually in the in the subtle balancing
of those of those few things and the way
you know a really easier kind of dumb
analogy to make it as to use is that you
know ultimately if you want to be the
best triathlete you can't you got to be
good at all three you got to be good at
swimming biking and running and that's
that's you can't be so good at one and
then so bad at the others is that's
that's not going to be you know that
that's not gonna be competitive and
that's kind of the way that I feel like
I've I've I've spent my life now the
last four to six years is really trying
to be like how can I be the best person
for me that's balancing like seven
disciplines as opposed to three well
yeah yeah I mean I I group them in with
you know family sport and business you
know those are kind of the three things
that are the focal points for me and and
finding the balance between those and
and how it EPS and flows through the
year and through you know cycles in your
own life and things like that but but
yeah it's been something good yeah I
mean I think there's this sense that if
you want to be the best triathlete in
the world or maybe the best athlete in
any discipline the best way to do that
is to you know live by yourself right
happy the moments a monkey a monkey
rocky all you do is do your thing
yeah [ __ ] yeah but if that was true that
every gold medal-winning athlete would
be living that lifestyle II it's not
true like I I had this conversation with
Kerri walsh-jennings
yeah it's very thing like she's married
and has kids and you know she will say
that there look it's been a bumpy road
but ultimately she believes that she's a
better volleyball player a long-term by
having this robust yeah life that on a
surface level would look like a
distraction from her being the best
volleyball player yes she can be and and
I think I I agree with that I think what
I was just saying you know everybody's
different and everybody has their
different capacity of what their
fulfillment where their fulfillment
where their happiness like lies and how
much do you feel like they need to
balance those things and but ultimately
yet probably for Carrie is similar to me
then that if I if I get to if I get too
far away from family or even from a
business then I start to feel
one-dimensional I have less energy I'm
less fulfilled and ultimately because of
that my training soccer is sacrificed
and my racing is sacrificed and and the
same thing goes with the other two as
well you know if I if you know I'll be
the first to say as a dad with two kids
if I'm if I spend all day every day with
my kids I Drive myself you know you know
yes go out I'm not a good person at the
end of those few days you know I'm not
I'm not my best person so so back to the
first you know startup you're working
100 hours a week
yeah at some point you realize like hey
I need I need this kind of fitness
athletic competitive aspect of my life
to return a little bit yeah and it was
it was it was a little bit yeah what
ended up happening was I ultimately just
woke up
you know one day and was like man and it
was presumably after a long night of
hanging out with my friends and drinking
beer and whatever else it just was like
I feel terrible you know and I need to I
need to start being active
my neck had healed I could I could run I
could ride a bike even a little bit and
and I just I just need to find reconnect
with that side of myself started doing
that I got interested in triathlon
because I had swam a little bit as
rehabilitation for my neck and and did a
triathlon and then and in that first
race like just rediscover this this
little like Saturday morning community
thing where everybody's out there at
7:30 in the morning and it's not crazy
competitive but it's competitive enough
and you exercise really hard and then
the Sun is up and you've done it 9:30
and you know you eat the peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches at the you know
thing and everybody's psyched yeah yeah
and I just I had forgotten about that
about that experience and then that
really got me back into it was it that
thing where you win the first race that
you ever and are probably typical yeah
yeah it was definitely but yeah but it
was that you know I mean you know you
come from an endurance background you
got a lot of you know you got a lot of
background in that so but it would but
for me it was you know yeah there was
validation that hey this is fun but it
but at that time it wasn't it was more
just it's just fun being active you know
and then it was and then I then I
actually that kind of made me think
started make me rethink rebalance my
life and moving away from the start up
reconnecting like I said with Lauren
Lauren was moving to Eugene so I went to
business school there and kind of
actually pause on the triathlon thing
for a couple years because I didn't feel
confident enough at that time in my life
that I could do something as as
irresponsible
I guess as trying to be a professional
triathlete that makes sense it's like oh
man now I can't do that I can't do that
I gotta I gotta be getting my MBA or
well whatever it took that's it that's
the burden you have of privilege you
know graduate from Stanford it feels
indulgent and irresponsible to like
shirk
it agree - I don't pursue some you know
weird thing that's probably not going to
be that lucrative yeah that was that was
exactly it and ultimately it was after
I'd finished Business School
Lauren was was racing professionally and
I had gotten enough kind of contacts
through Business School to do some
consulting work where I could make some
money on the side in addition to the
economy had just completely imploded so
there were like you know 100,000 MBAs
had been laid off in the five months
before I'd like to be touring my
graduated but yeah that was literally
yeah summer of 2009 was when I graduated
whoo and I got my MBA and so I started
consulting and then talked with Lauren
and was like hey I think you know maybe
I want to I want to try seeing if I can
be a professional triathlete they even
know what that meant
and how many races had you done at this
point I'd done just I'd done one that
one little season where I did the thing
you know and then it was an age group er
and that was it and so the so what I
ended up doing was I spent the summer
with Laura and I was consulting and then
through the winter and then I signed up
for Escape from Alcatraz
the following year 2010 and I went down
there as an amateur and and I finished
like sixth or seventh in the pro field
as an amateur had the fastest run right
and that was the first time where I was
like oh man maybe you know oh if I had
been in the pro field I would have won
$750 Wow it really gets back to the
Union exactly like but you know but that
was that was a felt like a taste of
success and then that and that was like
this little bit of validation that was
like okay maybe I can continue to do
this and that's what that was that it
was after that that I got that I hired
my coach and everything else started
going was that Matt Dixon yeah from the
get-go he's getting on your coach yeah
Lindsey Corbin who you know is a very
successful American pro
she was a high school classmate of mine
and and then mattli a know how you went
to I didn't know that yeah when I went
to high school you we were on the
cross-country team together so those
were the two people that I knew in
triathlon and they were both coached by
Matt and and so I talked to Matt I
really liked him we clicked quickly and
and then he started coaching me kind of
at the end of that 2010 year and then it
was and then 2011 was where I when I
started my pro writer and so there's
this you know mythic story about the
birth of your professor I'm sure you've
told a million times but but it is
amazing right so walk me through yes yes
oh I mean the story goes that I went I'd
spent the whole winter training with
with a real coach and kind of was part
of this team and I went down to
Galveston actually 70.3 to race my first
half ironman and at my first half
ironman as a pro I made every mistake
you can make in the book I got down
there saw how flat the course was
decided that I needed to be more
aerodynamic so I lowered my position
brought it down it was the last person
out of the water
biked out bike back as hard as I could
it was making up time but basically my
whole back and might like my glutes like
everything seized up on the end of the
bike I was I was actually literally
riding out of the saddle for the last
like 3 or 4 miles of the bike ride and
then ultimately had dropped out because
I was hurt I was hurting so bad on the
run and so it was super disappointed you
know kind of had these aspirations of
this is my debut I wanted to go do this
and didn't really know what to do next
but it turned out that Matt the guy
mentioned Matt Ledo was gonna head down
for a wildflower just two weeks later
and he basically was like you should
come down awhile far with me mostly
because he knew I would be in Ben I
would drive with him so he would have
somebody that could drive half the half
the way and I head down there and
on the way just the day before we left
the other piece of this story is my I
was out on my last training ride on my
bike I went through a pothole my bike
broke that so the garbin actually
cracked and so in a last-minute deal I
got a I got a friend's bike threw it in
the pan borrowed a bunch of you know
stuff from that I'd never worn an arrow
helmet before I didn't have a wetsuit
had this kind of hand-me-down unbranded
triathlon race kit and then these um you
know gas station aviators that I was
wearing and and then little did you know
yeah yeah and you know as the story goes
you know I swam pretty poorly like I
normally do I had a decent ride and rode
up into about a 10th place and then it's
a really challenging
yeah win course very slow very
challenging which is really good for me
because it just meant another 20 minutes
on the bike and to try to catch up from
the swim and then the run is about as a
heart of a half ironman run as you get
and so the run is also let's say 10
minutes long so you have three you have
30 more minutes of doing the stuff that
I'm good at in the race than a normal
race and and the run was this like I
still remember it very vividly it was
like I get off the bike and I hear as
I'm leaving this I'm starting the run um
in 10th place I was like oh my god I'm
in 10th place at wildflower like I'm
super this is really exciting and I
start passing people just bit by bit you
know eight nine or eight seven six
I remember seeing Jordan rap and fourth
place a few hundred meters in front of
me being like wow that's fourth place
and that's Jordan rap and I can't
believe I'm having this great race and
then I get all the way through and I
move into second place with a mile and a
half to go and I can see the guy then in
in the lead you know he's still a long
ways up but he's hurting and people as
I'm running along they're like
IRA actually remember Tim Carlson who
works for slow-twitch he was taking
pictures of me and he kept coming back
and he was like who are you you get lost
he's trying to like text the race
organizers Lucas no you let them know
cuz they don't know who I am
I passed the guy right at the beginning
of the deep downhill towards that with
about less than a mile to go eating it
was a Clayton fatale out of Australia a
super-strong swim biker and who had this
massive gap and I got a and I came down
and I just I remember I crossed the
finish line and they the announcer goes
and here he is our men's champion and
then he holds the microphone away from
his face he's like dude what's your name
and the the reason they didn't they
literally didn't know who I was is
because I had signed up so late they had
given me a number that was like after
the women's numbers because they were
kind of out in numbers and it just
didn't she it didn't get ya entered into
the system so so for people that are
listening I mean wildflowers this
legendary race been going on forever and
it's it's quite an event you go you
can't you can't most people stay in
tents or RVs there's a hotel or anything
like that super challenging course but
but a really prestigious yeah early
season race and to go from anonymity to
winning that race it's just like that
doesn't happen like so suddenly
overnight you're like this like who is
this guy like you're the next greatest
thing well yeah it was it was kind of
yeah it was it was the whole story
erupts are up is the whole story or like
you borrowed the bike yeah this guy
doesn't even have his own bike and he's
wearing like a station cool like like
Charlie's are the most geeked out and
yeah their gear and the sunglasses there
I mean getting everything wholly
ridiculous is totally honest but the
idea that somebody would be wearing like
aviators from a gas station is just like
that doesn't compute yeah at all yeah it
was it was bizarre and then I think the
thing that kind of like sealed it then
you know going viral within the sense of
going viral within the triathalon
community which is not really viral yes
like 10 10 or 12 people shared it was
this this this finish line interview
that I had where I was just freaking out
about you know oh my god my buddy's
gonna [ __ ] is he's gonna [ __ ] his pants
when he finds out I won while her and
Nick who let me borrow his bike you know
and so there was kind of there was this
legitimate like authenticity about it
which was legitimately there that was
kind of like a cool in it there's an
innocence yeah there was an innocence to
it and and people latched on to that and
that was really awesome and it there was
no better way for me to come on to the
scene than that thing and then
ultimately that race then ultimately
ended up meeting even so much more to me
down the road but that but that really
launched my career and gave me the the
tools the foundation necessary to
actually make a living in the sport
because of the story more so than the
actual wins right you know and that
right back to what we are a little bit
what we were talking about is like you
know making it making yourself you know
an actual like somebody that people want
to follow regardless of you know they 1x
race or what oh that's that's a new
thing in the developed that was getting
just we just start pro athlete yeah like
what is your story and how we're telling
it yeah is is almost as important as you
know your race results you could argue
in the Instagram influence or age that
were in it's more important and then
actually from a I'll tell you from a
business side you know that it probably
is you know in terms of businesses
looking to spend money on you know
advertising basically well certain
somewhat upon every pro athlete to think
of themselves as as a business marketing
and yeah and how are they you know how
are they sharing their story how are
they telling it what is it that they
have to offer that somebody yes doesn't
in taking that seriously like
shouldering that responsibility and you
know we've talked in the past I mean
this is something that I think that
you've done
very well but not in a like some kind of
contrived sense it's like a natural
outgrowth of who you are like I feel
like you and Lauren together are natural
storytellers like yeah thank you you're
very funny and like how you you share
like like the thing that's on your
Twitter now that about the carbs sticker
and then like you know Chad gets in the
car and drives up like it's like like
this is just this clear this is like
your song ability you know it's fun and
it's very authentic to who you are
thanks natural yeah but when I look at
that and I kind of like okay I'm
deconstructing this I'm like least like
really good at like sharing something
that allows people who are interested in
what you're doing to like emotionally
connect with yeah what you're up to
Wow thank you I appreciate that and you
know that's I always way before I ever
got into racing or doing any of the
stuff that I'm doing now my my family
I'll tribute tribute that to my dad my
dad's side of the family my dad was just
a and his whole family or just
storytellers uh-huh and you know kind of
like gather around the fire or around
the dinner table just telling [ __ ]
stories about you know them growing up
and and stuff like that and I always
those are some of my favorite memories
just having my dad kind of my dad and my
dad's brothers kind of go around the
horn telling stories and I grew up
listening to stories like that and then
retelling him myself and and then so
I've I get a lot of joy at legitimate
joy out of telling those stories making
them funny making them entertaining
also making them also you know telling
the truth I think and talking about the
you know being honest when I when I have
a not just a shitty race but like a
heartbreaking race after training you
know for a year for something and in to
a certain extent that that experience of
telling those stories I think it has
made the sport for me not only more
interesting but more sustainable yeah
both as a person and as a professional
and
so it's been a really lucky and great
discovery to go through I think well
when you're a storyteller it takes it
takes the you're able to take those low
moments and just translate them into
something else that's valuable right
like everything's a story so I have a
shitty race well what can I make out of
this that I can share with other people
like I know you were are you still
writing the column for try I'm not
anymore yet for you yeah yeah where you
would do that everything yeah and and in
a lot of ways the the tough you know the
stories the the unsuccessful coke
quote-unquote stories are more
interesting and more power and powerful
to most people yeah because they can
connect with your humanity
exactly it is and they're and they're
harder to write but there but then
they're more fulfilling to and you put
when you put them out there so yeah it's
interesting so you go on to dominate
Wildflower part of a decade race like
six times right yeah thank you that
becomes like your thing yeah and then
this whole aviator shades thing becomes
like a thing you know everyone's Sally
wearing aviators all of a sudden and for
years you were still wearing like the
shitty yeah station version for sure cuz
I lose them all this um but then like
enter stage left
Roka yeah Stanford guys yeah effort
swimmers yeah I go way back with those
guys much older than them but I remember
the very early days when they launched
this company and it was just you know is
it's the classic you know our garage
kind of thing yeah with one wetsuit and
now they've built it into this brand
that's quickly you know becoming it's on
the it's like they're slowly broadening
the aperture yeah and to become a
lifestyle brand to transcend triathlon
yeah to become really Under Armour sized
yeah thing but you've been collaborating
with them
from the very early day so talk about
that really yeah it's been it's really
funny the that relationship goes back
like you said to Stanford connection I
had a friend of mine introduced me via
email to Robin Curt who are the
co-founders of roca and he said hey
these guys are starting a wetsuit
company and they want to try to make you
faster which to me was amazed
because I was like rebels yeah and so no
but no swimming company is there
literally paying me to not wear their
wetsuits right and so um for these guys
to come to me and be like we want to
build a wetsuit for for the average
swimmer which is you try to make you
faster that was interesting we started
working together they were just two of
the most
I don't know brilliant and hardworking
and simultaneously hard-working people
at ever met rob was like a working in a
law firm as a lawyer yeah throughout
most of this development yeah in like
the early days of the company and
they're they're both yeah he was and he
was you know just working his ass off
you know has been for probably his
entire life you know Rob and and then
Kurt's like incredibly creatively
talented so like the two of these guys
you get Rob's kind of like efficiency
he's like one of the most efficient
purse people I know in terms of his
output and then and then Kurt who's one
of the most creative people I know you
get them together and just like it was a
great match yeah and they um we started
working on this wet suit the wet suit
was phenomenal we you know we launched
it I was kind of their first athlete and
and kind of part of the original kind of
barely formation of the company and then
and then because I was wearing this
these aviators thing I remember on a
long drive back from a race I was
talking to rob and it's like you know I
would I would really like to I think
there's something to making an actual
aviator that has that has performance
characteristics and it's like something
that you can wear casually but that you
could wear that you feel comfortable
airing casually but that you would wear
as that you could legitimately where
running or cycling and they they were
like they were intrigued with the idea
to but it was kind of like hey we got
wetsuits you know we're gonna work on
this yeah and so but then it was a
couple few years later when they started
to grow and Rob raised some money and he
was like I think we're gonna look at
glasses are you interested and we
started talking about it and started
making the making an actual aviator
which is you
now if you believe that we're actually
doing this I just say no it's we're
gonna convince all these people were
baby shades when they when they get on
it and it's so insane I mean really it
is but but it's it's kind of Awesome you
know like it it's probably it's
something that I'm very that I'm very
proud of you know and then the and then
the cool kind of story of the original
Roca performance aviator phantom is what
it's called the is that Kurt literally
had the first prototype shipped directly
to me from Japan in two lands arathi to
Iron Man lands arathi in the Canary
Islands in 2016 and I got them as I was
leaving for to check in my iron man bag
I tried them on they fit great
I moved my face around they didn't fall
off I was like they looked off better
than throw it into my trap into my
transition bag the next day I had swim
bike I'm in like sixth or eighth place I
get I'm going to get into my transition
bag put on my shoes and I put on my Roca
aviators and I and I ran down yeah I ran
down yawn for day no because one of the
best triathletes ever and won that race
and you know I will always qualify that
with saying it was kind of a training
race for yawn I'm not equated myself to
yawn but it was a great race for me one
of my best moments ever and I won this
big Ironman against a strong field you
know literally running my first 26 miles
ever in those in those shades it was
pretty awesome it's awesome yeah it was
cool and then you know hundreds of
thousands of people later everyone
suddenly the next day everybody yeah
there are it's like you have created
this fashion you know
something I never in a million years
would have ever thought it's a guy that
you know Lauren gives me [ __ ] as the guy
that was still wearing you know pleated
jeans all through call that irony yeah
that I have a fashion statement yeah
now it's good and and still working with
those guys today right yeah definitely
yeah they've been great they just that
that you know and not to over plug the
glasses but they just got a big PR shout
out from Popular Mechanics is like
running sunglasses so it's just it's
like you said when if I take a step back
and I'm like seven or eight years ago to
think of it like I just never would have
thought that that would happen well yeah
that's not speaking up on the whiteboard
no yeah that's yeah it's it's cool so
I'm very I'm very very proud of it yeah
and very very happy and proud of those
guys I mean really they did all the work
right sorry
yeah so you've had all these wins you
know Lance Roddy and and wildflower you
had an incredible race at at Roth last
year you were third yeah they ran like a
244 yeah crazy yeah that's like insane
um and you know I look at your race
results and I follow you on Strava and
like I see these run workouts that you
do it I can't even fathom being able to
run that fast he's like so amazing and
yet in the context of triathlon it's
like it's all about Kona yeah things
about totally yeah if you're not winning
Kona no one knows who you are you know
are you relevant or whatever and I think
it's you know is I'm interested in your
perspective on how all that works it
kind of goes back to what we're saying
before like there's this very very like
thin top tier you know level people who
are winning Kona and then there's like
and then there's like just below that
there's guys like you yeah who are just
incredible at what they do and yet
because it's all about Kona there's this
sense of like being an also-ran
yeah thing like that yeah it is it's a
really hard I didn't realize I didn't
understand the kind of Kona centric
mindset of triathlon when I got into it
because I to be I'm one of those rare
guys that got into racing professional
triathlon who didn't know [ __ ] about
triathlon until I was thirty you know I
didn't it was just wasn't on the radar
for me
athletically and so um I didn't know
about the history of Kona I didn't know
about the history of Ironman or anything
like that and when I went to Kona the
first year to spectate I was like wow
this is really this pretty big deal
and then really when you start to learn
about it through the professional side
of the sport and understanding where all
the bonuses are for sponsorships and all
the incentives or are they're all built
around a kona centric model like that's
where you can get paid everything else
is kind of like you said like an
also-ran kind of lead-up to Kona all
most of the sponsors want you to be in
Kona and to break even on Kona as an
athlete you have to get top ten I mean
no doubt even even the way that they
have it right now seventh eighth ninth
there you're probably pretty close I
can't remember exactly what the prize
money is but it's in the low thousands
of dollars and it's so expensive to get
over there and you know just on the trip
itself much less the whole year right
going into it and then so so then you
know and you're not getting bonuses for
top ten at Kona you're getting bonuses
for top three to five tops and the
opportunity cost you're not racing
elsewhere because all your eggs are in
that basket so it's it's really hard so
I mean so for better and for worse as a
business guy in the first two or three
years of my career I was like and unless
I think I can win Kona which to be
honest right off the bat I'm like I
can't win Kona that's you know it
exposes all my weaknesses as an athlete
the heat the the sweat the swim is a
bigger deal it's it's a grouped up bike
ride there's there's not as much chance
for me to make up time so I can't win
Kona unless I think I can win Kona I
better not make cone of the focus of my
career because it's gonna be I'm not
gonna first of all I won't be happy and
second of all I'm not gonna make any
money doing that like you can't you put
all your eggs in that basket it's not
gonna pay out and so for you know for
better and for worse I steered away from
that for a long time until about I even
wrote one of my most popular articles
was I'm not an Ironman and that's okay
right yeah and and that really resonated
with having to apologize yeah exactly
that really resonated with people and
then and ultimately the reason I wanted
to
do Kona was not because of the financial
implications of it or anything like that
it was just it was really just like I
just felt like if I hadn't got if I had
gone through eight to ten years of being
a professional triathlete and I hadn't
done Kona I would have regretted it you
know even though I knew it wasn't gonna
be a great race for me and but and but I
could still try to do the best I could
there and that was what I tried to do
but but yeah but it was always really
important for me to make my career about
other challenges both externally and
internally you know to to feel more
fulfilled and more I guess more balanced
and just pursuing things that I was
there I was interested in right yeah
well let's talk about the training and
and you know what it's like working
underneath underneath mat yeah I guess
first of all like what is it that you've
gleaned you know the most from working
with you know such a legendary coach
yeah I think how to train for these
things I think Matt's what I like about
Matt you know and I'll qualify this by
saying what yo Matt for better and for
worse has been my coach my whole career
right so I haven't experienced really
anybody else but I think the thing that
it clicked with with Matt was that he
even when I started triathlon I had
picky bars as a business I was already
like less of a focused full gas
professional triathlete I still had this
other thing and I was married so he knew
right away I wasn't gonna be training 30
to 40 hours a week living the rocky monk
style and he got that he understood that
and he's like I think we can I think you
can be a good a better athlete even
because of this balance of you but it
but it's gonna take a different training
philosophy a training philosophy that
doesn't put all the value on tons of
time training it puts it on this kind of
balanced physiological stress throughout
the various aspects of your life and
balancing heavy training load with light
life load heavy life load with light
training load and that was that that was
like the fundamental thing that I liked
about Matt and then as I progressed
through my career and ultimately became
more successful both in racing and on
the business side and more demands with
family that interweaving and inner
balance just became more and more so
important because it was like everything
was just operating now at a higher level
yeah so so and I think that and I think
if you know if I could differentiate
Matt from other coaches in the space I
think that's really his his sweet spot
is coaching like he says himself the
time-starved athletes you know guys that
are executives or family guys or
whatever that are trying to that are
still have goals they're still trying to
do something great maybe they're trying
to qualify for Kona or do or do whatever
it is but they're balancing it with
legitimate demands on their time and
energy elsewhere yeah yeah which is
basically almost everybody yeah it is I
mean really are totally who are just
completely turning their entire exactly
this yeah so so a training block for you
I mean what would that typically look
like in terms of the balance between you
know the kind of zone to aerobic work
versus you know intensity tempo type
training like what is that
that combination generally it is let's
see I'll tell you what it's like it's
really go by feel and particularly the
last like three to four years and the or
I guess let's head here I know you know
they want to know exactly what don't use
these devices it's not that guys I'm
sorry that's just not you know what it
ends up being is a couple few hard days
a week a couple few easy days a week and
mixing in some volume and but so much of
it is is based on how I feel you know
and that that really is to me the crux
of I think being successful in any
athletic
endeavor but also the crux of the of the
success of the relationship between Matt
and I is his confidence in me to make my
own decisions day to day to manipulate
his plan and then my confidence in him
to build a plan that is manipulatable
and that that that ultimately I can you
know communicate back to him this is
what works and what doesn't so in other
words he doesn't just say here's your 12
workouts for the week and you do them
when I say you do them it's more like
make sure you get you hit these kind of
general areas or benches and however you
can work that into what your schedule
looks like for the week you like that's
up to you that's pretty that's a lot
that that's what you described at first
was how it started
uh-huh and then really over the last
like three or four years as picky bars
really grew I had my first kid and then
my second kid
it was more like here's kind of here's
what I would like you to achieve and
then I'd look at my schedule
and I'd be like well I've got this
meeting on whatever and I'm traveling
this day so I'm gonna do Wednesday's
work out on Tuesday and I'm gonna make
my easy day whatever and then if I feel
like [ __ ] on Tuesday that I'm gonna just
do that one I'm gonna scrap it or but or
if I feel good I'm gonna I'm gonna gas
it and that's that's ultimately what
it's become now I think the ability to
really go on on feel as you say comes
with experience
yeah tremendous amount of experience so
you have like you know years of yeah
understanding what that means mixed with
you know having done enough work to
understand the nuance of that right yeah
like when when am I being being a puss
you know and when when do what when am I
really like butting up against like
maybe putting in too much yeah you know
like those things only come with like
years and years and years of having done
this yeah it's it's totally true you
know so it's not I wish there was a like
and easily more easily like Glee mobile
are understandable like tidbit I could
give to you know listeners trying to try
to have trying to find that line but it
does come from experience but
I would say that the way that I would
qualify that with is that most endurance
athletes competitive endurance athletes
or aspirational endurance athletes have
have a bigger problem with knowing when
to pull back then when to push forward
and at least that's that's been my
experience with the many many age
groupers that I've interacted with and
done articles with and talk to and
whatever else so a lot of it is the the
biggest thing I think is a as an athlete
for most people is having the confidence
to pull back when things aren't going
right and not very different on a
discipline yeah but it is still a
discipline it is it definitely and I
think what happens with the more time
crunched you know among us is they have
a set amount of time and they feel like
they have to the only way that they're
really maximizing that is if they just
don't fold so even if they're only have
45 minutes yeah you know every every day
or something like that you can't gas it
out like that yeah you're gonna have a
problem you're gonna get injured
absolutely so it's just not the way to
go
yeah what is some of the other I love
asking pro triathlete yeah but what are
some of the other things that you see
like the typical amateur triathletes or
multi-sport athletes out there doing
where you're like what are they doing
yeah I mean the most typical thing is is
related to what we just talked about but
it's basically just not taking your easy
days easy right that's the that's the
number one problem in amateur triathlon
nowadays people go out they do their
card workouts great that's hard
you're gas from that but then they go
out riding with their buddies and
somebody's going out for a straw Visayan
straw ever I have this trauma guys in
here the other day and I was like listen
I had to like get off the platform yeah
that they were whoa and they've ruined
that you can't go yeah you can't go easy
you it is and so that's so that that's
problem number one you know
and then and then I think more generally
it's like it's finding you know just an
appropriate amount of building an
appropriate amount of recovery in
general such that your that the the load
of each week isn't building on itself to
where you then get to the end of week
eight and you're just smoked there's an
end you you can't recover in time for
your race yeah and and so I think I
think those are the two yeah those are
those are the two main things that maybe
finding some way to period always what
you're doing yeah exactly I do it as
scientifically is the way you like Matt
and you would do it for your I mean you
know and that's where I think so much of
it comes back to feel you know cuz you
because there are so many other things
at play like your your your training
plan is only perfect on the day that you
make it you know and then there are all
these other variables that come in like
my kid kept me up last night or you know
I had this really stressful phone call
with a supplier whatever it is and that
those things affect you you know and so
if you don't if you don't listen to the
listen to those things that listen to
your body then ultimately you're just
kind of like plowing through on this
thing it doesn't make any more sense
yeah when you're rigidly holding on to
that learning routine and that's come
hell or high water you're gonna have
like an emotional problem and that's
usually an ego thing you're doing that
because you feel like you're being weak
by letting go of the word you're so
afraid yeah yeah okay I'm not gonna be
able to finish this race and right -
exactly
yeah totally this plan yeah it's hard
and all that kind of stuff how do you
what's your relationship with all the
the devices and you know self
optimization movement so as much as you
know I am I go by feel 100 percent
person but I'm also an engineer an
engineer yeah so I can I you know I like
geeking out on the data but what data
ends up being for me is like a kind of
like this post work
catharsis thing more than it is like a
god hit this or else my workout is a
failure type of thing I like to go back
I mean I I love Strava you know I love
Swift I love I have a power meter on my
stuff I I track my heart rate in my in
my pace most the time a lot of other
crazy programs like gold and cheetah and
all that kind of stuff now I don't I
don't know that one yeah you got a oh
there's more levels I mean the graphs
are only only a mechanical understand
that yeah that's funny no but I do I
mean I do like that stuff you know I'll
go out I'll do Strava you know what I'll
do now I mean I'll integrate Strava into
my workout if I have some you know thing
where I'm doing three times twelve
minutes man I've got to find a 12-minute
segment and try to get the get my
fastest time or get a kom up that thing
because what better motivation on your
12-minute segment than having something
like that you know so so yeah usually
try to use that stuff you know
try not to be pay too much attention to
it but but definitely using it I would
suspect though that somebody with your
engineering background and somebody
who's so connected to your own in a
physical body and the experience that
you've had that you can be wearing you
could have the power meter and the
heartrate Montes tough but when you're
out doing intervals you know if I was to
say to you after each repeat like you
know what was your what was your power
on that yeah probably tell me without
looking like you would you know within a
degree been an out there so at some
point that's like with that experience
the feel comes in because you're so
connected like you know what your hurry
it is you know what you're putting what
you're throwing down and you can gauge
that more accurately I think so and and
and and and as importantly it's it's
like if the prescription for the workout
is 350 watts or whatever or whatever
interval and I get out on that first or
second interval and 350 watts just isn't
happening then it's then it's just I
just changed the prescription you know I
mean that's that's the thing like I
might be looking at the power meter but
it's not like you're not gonna do it
until you find yeah it's
that's not it you know that's the thing
I mean but then there might be days
where 350 watts is the prescription but
hey I feel good at 400 so just keep it
going yeah you know I mean and and that
and that that's the steps of flip side
of it what's the recovery routine for
you
nowadays it's you know fuel first
obviously eating eating healthy and then
spending time spending as much time as I
can with my kids you know that's the
that's the main thing there's not to me
nothing is better than watching a movie
with my like five-year-old you know
watching some cartoon reliving we want
we watched a lad in the other day which
which was like right in the prime for me
in terms of I probably watched that 50
times when I was growing up not 50 times
but a lot not a lot that 30 years later
I still remembered a lot of the lines
which is crazy I couldn't believe it
while I was watching how many of the
lines I knew were coming before they
they said it so about that I don't know
that's that's recovered how was your
daughter now daughters one-and-a-half
yeah and she's she's great she's she's
super super fun it's been it's actually
been a very different relationship with
her I think partially because she's a
girl but more importantly because I'm
more present with her than I was with my
kid when he was that age you know
zadie was born five days before Kona my
second Kona which was brutal they left
for Kona came back and then but then
since then you know been a much I've had
much more time with her than I did with
Jude during that stage so it's been so
the connection is is different you know
it feels a little bit deeper you know in
a weird way but my connection with Jude
is fantastic but it's just a little bit
different yeah but there's something
there's something special about girl
dads and girls I think there must be
right yeah I mean yeah you know yeah
there must be like yeah it's a little
bit different there is like a more
naturally
you know protective and supportive right
vibe there that as opposed to kind of
you know getting the the little guy to
like cut us you know cuz cut his chops
or whatever and yeah yeah there's like
there's it there's a sweetness and yeah
there is yeah there really is it's yeah
yeah she she lights me up she's she's
amazing
so let's talk about nutrition a little
bit yeah of course
cuz it also like dovetails and yeah
Vicky bars and what you're doing yeah
we're in the midst of this like low carb
and I forgot that I love cars I know I
will say got a mailbag tonight I'm gonna
mail you one because I spaced out right
as I was leaving and I when I got on the
plane I was like oh crap I forgot Rich's
shirt so talking through like your
perspective on all of this well I mean
you know so my wife Lauren is the she's
really the the nutritional foundation of
our company she comes from a human
biology background Stanford educated for
long time pro athlete right and I'm more
of like the business you know business
marketing guy but but so but our our
general philosophy as as a family is
just a healthy sustainable balance you
know and and to in to us and and that's
our that's our philosophy in life right
I mean all this stuff that we've been
talking about like going a hundred hours
a week doing this or 40 hours a week
training and ultimately not feeling like
you're the best version of yourself in
either of those things I ultimately
think that you know the dieting industry
is exactly that it's it's prescribing to
the diet of the month or whatever that's
some extreme thing that's and because
it's extreme it's easy to grasp and
that's what's nice about it right it's
easy it's easy to grasp for it's easier
to it's easier to live in that space for
a short amount of time than it is to be
sustainably healthy for a long time
right because that's vague yeah we can't
be marketed in a way where anyone can
specifically profit off its like going
off a feel you know like people want to
hear well I need to have 60% of doing
this
30% of doing this and whatever you know
I need to have this many carbs this mint
this you know or no carbs you did it is
zero carb and like I'm gonna power my my
multi-sport career without the one thing
my cells actually need to generate
energy I've got this idea I'm gonna it's
so dumb I feel dumb even mentioning it
cuz it's just a it's just a fun a dumb
funny idea but I want to make the picky
diet for picky bars you know just a
funny like campaign that's basically
like you know everything's on the picky
diet just don't be an [ __ ] that's the
crux of the whole thing is ice cream on
the pita yeah just just don't be an
[ __ ]
right you know and so um but I mean
that's so that's our general nutritional
philosophy is like you know we avoid
extremes we try to eat generally very
sustainably healthy and by sustainable
sustainable in and of itself means
avoiding extremes you know and and so
that's a that's a mix of healthy you
know foods and as natural and
unprocessed as possible and and then but
there's there's room you know I I think
there's a room in every diet for it for
a bit of everything you know and just
just in healthy moderation so so but the
the bars are all dairy free and gluten
free yeah yeah they are yeah we avoided
those things we avoided those things
primarily because of the impact that
they have on people's digestion system
when they're when you're exercising a
whole bunch that was them the the
original the original bar that Lauren
created was basically like what's the
what's the healthiest real food bar that
I can give to Jesse when he's exercising
a ton that will be the least upsetting
on his stomach and those two things tend
to be the most upsetting and was this
born out of having issues with other
products that were available because
yeah yeah
to have your brain examined to say like
I know I know the business we're gonna
go into I mean we ran out of this market
where there's like a thousand competitor
it wasn't a business thing you know it
was it was just a legitimate need that
Lauren sensed you know in the and the
not so savory part of the story was
basically I was having a bunch of a
bunch of stomach issues that Lauren
wasn't very happy about around the house
and training a ton and eating a ton and
Lauren was like and we got a I gotta
find something for you to be eating if
you're eating a bunch you know every day
you got to have something that's better
on your stomach and and so the idea was
kind of taking the best of you know at
that time what existed in like a power
bar which is like sports performance
nutritional principles but then marrying
that with like a Laura bar which would
be like you know just just basic like
fruits and nuts yeah and they'll yeah
and kind of taking combining those two
things and that's ultimately what became
a picky bar and Lauren created them for
me and then had and then her and her and
our other co-founder her friend Steph
just started selling them to their
friends at this random like local
running workout that they that they kind
of coached every Thursday night and
people started buying them and that was
the dow's the genesis of the whole
company and so it definitely wasn't
ironically I just finished Business
School right and so I just gone through
all this like here's your here's how you
do your business plan your financial
model yadda yadda yadda none of that
SWOT analysis no would not that there
was none of that
uh-huh and it was just you know and I'm
glad that there wasn't ultimately
because it would have discouraged us
from doing it yeah because it is the
best things percolate up or exactly it's
just it you know yeah it's been and
that's what it's been and it's it is a
industry I would never encourage people
to get into it's so competitive it's so
cache intensive particularly now with
the investment that that's that's been
coming into you know we're talking about
I'm down here I'm in LA for Expo West
right
which is the which is the largest food
trait I think the largest food trade
show in the US and has to be there is so
big and so you can even just in the
brief number of years that I've been
going down there I can see the growth of
it through the investment that is being
had by private equity firms and
everything else so so for us we're still
a completely independently owned and
operated company by just us and that's
you haven't taken any outside of we
haven't not yet angel fauna garden we
have it yeah it's something I'm
evaluating now but because we're
reaching the point now where we're big
enough we are starting to be we're
starting to barely play in those big
fields and against the big guys and it's
pretty it's it's pretty hard to do that
you know on your own so so you're in
this position now you got what like ten
employees yeah ten employees and you're
selling some retail right but you also
have direct a consumer model so yeah I'm
playing with both of those yeah I mean
the cool thing that the I think may be
the most interesting or unique part of
our business because the bars and and
the in the oatmeal and the granola there
there are they're great products but if
I'm to be if I'm gonna be totally humbly
honest and say like is this totally
uniquely differentiated in this sea of
products it's pretty hard to do that
right but what I do think is unique
about our company is that we started it
online through social media and through
our own racing and PR and like the
stories that we've talked about and and
even more so with Lauren and and because
of that we have this ecommerce we have
this ecommerce presence but I would call
it even more humbly call it more than
that it's like a community of people
that support the company and support the
products online yeah you come in
position it like you're you're a member
of a club voice yeah we literally have a
thing called the picky
which is a monthly subscription to any
of our products and at any interval that
you that you wanted to get you get a
discount but that is that has their
there has been a legitimate community
that is created around that we get PE a
t-shirt so those guys they get a we're
just sending out an email today where
they get a helped us design our next
thing they help us with our all of our
new products go through the picky Club
before their their launch so it's cool
when I go to races and I see and people
come up and they have a piggy club shirt
on I mean that's like it's a cool deal
and that's the most unique aspect of our
business so that's well it goes back to
storytelling it really does yeah and you
have a very authentic story that you can
tell around that and that you continue I
mean like I love it when you put those
look like you have your board meeting
and you're in your wetsuit it's [ __ ]
awesome hey you know what I mean like
does that you know yeah thank you and I
think that stuff is really cool and it
speaks to you know the authenticity of
the brand yes and you know like the more
like what I'm learning just talking to
you here is like this is really a
conversation about about balance like I
feel like there's a cultural discussion
happening right now yeah about like
balance and what does that mean forget
about balance be present and then we're
talking to like endurance athletes or
ultra endurance athletes like these are
not balanced people yeah but I'm getting
like this super balanced vibe from you
like that you feel like you're doing
your best when everything is kind of
operating like when when all these gears
are kind of churning yeah you know in a
healthy way
yeah I don't yeah I mean you know maybe
but I don't know if balance is the right
word for it or not but I think it's I
think it is like a healthy interweaving
of various aspects of life you know and
and ultimately feeling you know you at
the same time you could say my life is
not balanced I don't rest that much
right okay well you're professional
triathlete yeah an entrepreneur you got
two kids one is one-and-a-half so you're
probably sleeping at all like this is
not a yes yeah it's not like yeah you
know it's
I'm working really hard I'm doing a lot
of stuff but I think what I'm trying to
do is not is simultaneously not
sacrificing so much of one thing at the
at the benefit of another but then but
then simultaneously allowing some
sacrifice of each of those things to
benefit each other you have to pay okay
yeah exactly of going sideways in every
category a little a little bit yeah and
your sense yeah exactly yeah so what
have you what it would have been some of
the big lessons that you've learned
along the entrepreneurial journey that
you've been on oh man I mean starting oh
my god it is it's been so hard that
seems like really straightforward like
you have a recipe you make these bars
and rattles you sell on the number one
and it's funny because Lauren Lauren
called me on the way here you know I bet
I was in the car for an hour and a half
on the drive over here and she was like
you should feel comfortable saying
whatever whatever you want and the the
number one the number one thing that
number one lesson I've learned is if
possible don't start a company with your
wife you know in all fairness you know
and I am Lauren is amazing and she knows
that I that I believe that and
incredibly talented and she brings so
much to me personally into piggy bars
and everything else but man that is
there are a lot of hats to wear when
you're trying to balance that in a
business and as this business has become
more than just us like you said now ten
employees you know thousands and
thousands of customers it's there are
stresses that go along with that that
are almost impossible to completely
separate from the house you know and
that that I can't come home and turn it
off and it's so hard yeah and so that's
been that's been really tough that's
been the hardest the the biggest
downside of it for sure as the toll it's
taken on Lauren and i's relationship and
then to a certain extent I'm super proud
of how we've to be perfectly honest how
we're still together and how we've
navigated that and and still strong and
healthy as a result of that but it has
not been easy so that that's that's been
one of the biggest things I mean as
somebody who you know works I work with
my wife yeah well not on anything but on
something yeah totally yeah it's it's
super challenging and hard we're very
different people and then when we're
home it's like it's very difficult to
talk about anything it is and you have
to make a really conscious effort to
create boundaries around that yeah stuff
because if you don't make cultivating
your relationship the first priority
then it's all house it's all going to
taking time bomb and it's even worse as
you know when you have kids too because
that amount of time that you get
together is compressed even more you
know like then there's all this pressure
it has to be meaningful yeah that's true
yeah totally we Lauren and I are doing
our date nights you know we do a date
night every week and at first it was
kind of it felt a little bit pressure
fall you know like oh this is our one
chance we've got three hours here you
know and now we've now we've we've
luckily settled into a groove where it's
like okay let's just do what we wants no
big deal but I can't remember what was
her you shared like you went and saw the
Sundance shorts alright so they're all
like about you know horrific Oh Oscar
rice nothing against the people that
created those films you know because I
can you know you can say they're great
from a filmmaking standpoint they're
great films the but the Oscar the
live-action Oscar shorts I mean four of
the five movies were about like violence
too young to like kids basically in some
way shape or form happening and it was
just like as a parent that's just like
that's like the last thing you want to
see you know you know it exists but you
don't want to be sitting through the
theater like watching that and that's
part of what makes maybe it's part of
what makes the movies so powerful but at
the same time we're like man one thing
this is through we don't want to be
doing this so what have you had to rely
on to get through you know those tricky
moments of you know trying to find some
equanimity in your marriage we you know
friends and family but also professional
advice I mean
we've been we've been to counseling
together for it you know for sure
and just a lot of communication and
luckily like ultimately this kind of
foundation it's like rock-solid
you know foundation to our relationship
that's like a man even if we're even if
we're deep into you know screaming in or
whatever about something it's still
there you know and and you just do your
best not to you know to navigate it as
positively as you can and I think
hopefully luckily we're through the
worst of it you know as the business
grows it gets it does get harder and
harder but you know Lauren has Donna has
we've been really conscientious of I
mentioned you before we started of
removing her from the kind of the daily
operations so the business can be at
least on a day to day level mine and she
doesn't really need to think about it
and I don't really need to interact with
her on a day-to-day basis on it so
that's been very conscientious and
hopefully even as we you know continue
to grow a whole bunch will be that will
set us up for you know success yeah well
Lauren first came on my radar probably
around the same time that you did right
was by way of her incredible blog like
she's using crater yeah you know it's
like her facility with words and her
ability to kind of like relate these
concepts around female empowerment and
support are amazing and it's like I was
just waiting for her to write a book
yeah I'm glad that I got on your show
first because then I don't have to
follow Lauren so but she huh I would
have had you guys both at the same time
because I think it'd be interesting for
you guys together to talk yeah yeah
we've never done that well you have your
own podcast now oh yeah yeah that's true
yeah that's true yeah we do we have a
podcast now yeah work play love podcast
which has been really fun it's actually
going back to the date night thing the
part of the reason we started that was
just to set aside an hour
right week where we just talked to each
other my wife and I have that same joke
it's like in order for us to actually
have a real conversation we have to
create yes like let's me answer some
people's questions because then we will
talk to each other and and and honestly
ideally and for our own benefit talk to
each other about not our problems about
other people's problems and then what do
we learn through through that and so
that's been really I'm gonna write in a
question for your party should happen
all about like your guys have problems
together
of course you don't yet know that's good
that's good um but no yeah I mean back
to your that Lauren's a great writer
she's she's working on some stuff right
now and you know she is you know she's
very very busy she's coaching and she's
a mom and she's still working with her
company was Elle up there in Seattle and
she one of the founders that comes
you're there from the very beginning but
it's not a founder but she was there
first kind of pro athletes she's a
partner there she's it's it's very much
a piece of of what she's doing now right
it's a really cool company so it's it's
all around you know female empowerment
and yeah celebrating Female Athlete yeah
it's it's women yeah that that's exactly
it it's it's the the products are
women's running apparel specifically
running in athletic apparel but the soul
of the company is exactly what you just
described you know and started by female
Bergesen Ferguson yeah female founder
super staunch you know supporter of you
know women's rights women's empowerment
feminism and Lauren very much so as well
the end of the whole ethos of the
company now is around that and and it's
a it's a great company did they make
great products but what they stand for
and you know what they message the
importance of what they message to women
and to to girls and everything else is
great you know yeah it's really cool so
she is working on a book though she is
working on a boat and I can tell you the
the
no she's right now you know the process
a lot better than I do but right now
she's just kind of writing little you
know tidbits little chapters here and
there of like various places in her life
you know little frames and a lot of it's
around her dad who passed away about who
was an important piece of her
development in her life and and then
just her athletic journey and then
ultimately like her personal journey and
it's very good obviously I'm I'm very
biased she's my wife and I think she's
she's incredible but she's incredible
writer but the bit that the bits that
I've read or are very very good so I'm
the unexcited it's a long ways out you
know you know until it's a long ways out
but it's it's cool it's it's fun for me
to see her have this legitimate project
that she's really sinking her teeth into
that she's getting a lot of value from
right personally and where do you want
to see picky bars go like what's the
what's the five 10-year vision for this
my vision the the long-term vision for
me would be that picky bars grows and
becomes a what I like to say a company
that Bend is proud of right so I was
born and raised in this town Central
Oregon Bend a lot of people have heard
about it now it's been on the cover of
outside magazine and much to the chagrin
place that you a lot of people what's
amazing is that when you think of Oregon
you think of Portland rain yeah and it's
actually very arid but it's very yeah
yeah it's beautiful very sunny like an
outdoor mouse town paradise so I'm like
a unicorn cuz I was born there you know
back when is like ten fifteen thousand
people it's over a hundred thousand now
but for me personally the most proud I
could feel about something a result of
the company of picky bars would be the
impact that it could have on that
community and basically be like you know
are we can we be a hundred person
there that's that's making great
products that that impact people
positively telling stories that impact
people positively all of our customers
but then but then also that's impacting
the community with with awesome jobs and
and giving back and and so to me that's
the that's like the end goal the dream
you know there are some companies that
exist like that been that are that I'm
modeling some of it off of and and so
you know do all the manufacturing and
co-packing and everything you don't know
yeah it's still weird we don't have this
scale you know I would love to do that
eventually and that would bring a whole
bunch more jobs into in the Central
Oregon which would be awesome in
addition to it would be cool just to
have you know 100% control over of our
supply chain top to bottom but you know
but you have to be you have to be quite
a bit bigger which is which is the plan
you know and so I mean we're hoping you
know we're hoping to grow or if we're
really focused on that on building that
picky Club community ultimately and that
like that ecommerce side because of the
well for two reasons one because it's so
it's so ludicrously expensive to be to
get into distribution because you're
competing against all those guys that
have 1015 million bucks behind them and
then and then but secondly because
that's our wheelhouse you know could
building and donating this yeah creating
education creating that connection
creating that community online like
that's what we know yeah you know I'm
not gonna pretend to know how to be in
Safeway you know but well and being on
the shelf and Whole Foods it's yeah
there's so many middlemen it's so it
just becomes like an advertisement
you're not making any money it really is
and and we've experienced that you know
bits and pieces could we do have some
distribution here and there and but so
I'm really focused on that ecommerce I
that picky Club specifically that that
could the kind of the the content and
the community curation that goes into
making that right now it's a very
valuable and I think cool and unique
subscription service that does have some
value outside of this subscription
to the products itself but I really want
to build that into like something that's
that's much much more than just that
just the delivery that you get you know
what are some things that you've learned
from your experience being a
professional athlete that have benefited
you as a know as an entrepreneur it's a
business owner the biggest thing would
just be just to keep going you know just
push through like because you're gonna
you know we have had I've you know I've
had lots of your puking on mile 12 yeah
like you know like hey this could change
yeah yeah or or even or even from like a
bigger picture perspective you're you
get an injury or you or you did
completely [ __ ] up your big race or
whatever happen you had a [ __ ] race
keep going because down the road there's
gonna be something else could happen
that you don't even expect that could
end up being bigger and better than
whatever it is you thought you were
trying to do and that that's how I've
experienced that athletically now
multiple times and I have now
experienced it in business multiple
times as well we've been through some
really hard stuff you know some of which
was our fault some of which was other
people's fault and times where I thought
the business was righted at its edge and
then but ultimately you know we kind of
go through those those down moments and
keep striving and things come out you
know brighter on the other side
hopefully do you feel like you you tap
into your experience as an athlete more
than you tap into like what you learned
in Business School yeah like what's
what's normally informative or
definitely evil to you the business
school stuff is is helpful but the that
just that general vibe of like working
hard to solve a problem or to overcome
an obstacle I mean that's there's just
no substitute for it
you know nobody has nobody has the
crystal ball you know and and I think at
one of the struggles that I had as a
young entrepreneur
coming particularly coming from an
engineering side was feeling like I
really wanted to or needed to have a a
plan a model an algorithm that said if I
do this this and this my business is
gonna end up this and then it's all
gonna work perfectly according to some
spreadsheet exactly I wanted a
spreadsheet that would tell me all the
answers and what I've learned now in
business and then through sport as well
is just that you cannot anticipate the
many many variables that are coming down
the road and so you just need to pick a
direction and try until you run into the
wall and then turn it and then go a
different way
you know and that's I try to do that
more and more often in business know so
you have Matt Dixon as your coach yeah
for your athletic career do you have
mentors or people that you rely on for
guiding you in the entrepreneurial
journey definitely yeah some some really
really great ones
Kevin Rutherford is the CEO of noon in
uun yeah the hydration company great
personal and professional mentor to me
Scott Allen is the CEO of Hydra flask
it's just you know make they make the
insulated water bottles both those guys
have been have been awesome
you know impact it very impactful to me
on on a professional level and and I've
got I've got a few others so you know
I've got Alcock Hren is a guy from my
business school times who's still an
advisor to me and I reach out to people
a lot way more than I used to I used to
be really really feel like I needed to
be able to figure it out on my own and
now I'm like as soon as I ball probably
almost a monoi Liso suit I run into a
problem I'm like oh who do I know that
knows this and who can I reach out to I
think those relationships are really
important in business though because
particularly owning and operating a
company because it's so it's so unique
there are so few people that are at that
level of it that it's it's it I just
find it very valuable to get in
site from people that are experiencing
those feelings whether that's saying yes
and re yeah exactly
so when you're talking to you know young
business you know business school
students or entrepreneurs other than
like look man you gotta like stay in it
to win it like yeah what is some of the
guidance that you like to wisdom that
you well I mean the one I mean those two
things that we just mentioned would be
the the next the next two most important
which is seek out mentors you know
that's that's super super important I
think a lot of young kids particularly
in the digital age feel like they can
just google it themselves and there's
you know I can't I can't overstate the
value of just talking to someone in
personally to help figure out whatever
problem is you're trying to solve and
then the second thing was related back
to what we said which is don't get hung
up on trying to know all the right
answers I think that's the biggest thing
that keeps young young entrepreneurs
from just trying something is feeling
like they need to have it all figured
out and even you could relate that to
young athletes to you know aspirational
triathletes I get that question like how
do I start well pick a couple races and
give yourself six months and just you
know see how it goes and in six more
months you'll know five times more than
you do right now and in business I think
it's the same thing
it's just like pick a direction validate
as quick as you can
and move on to the next decision with
the new information that you have based
on on that validation you know my mom
had this I'm sure it's it's probably a
famous quote from somebody that I should
know but it's it's a it is forever
emblazoned on a cartoon magnet that goes
on my mom's refrigerator
it says sometimes you just have to jump
and build your wings on the way down
uh-huh right and that's the way that's
the way that I feel about business
sometimes it's like well you you know
you got to go down so you're not really
sure how you're gonna land but like
let's just start going down well right
you know we'll find more as we get as we
get along well that's like your first
wildflower too
totally yeah getting the bike on though
yeah like not knowing anything about
anything and just figuring it out yeah
and I like how you didn't just go out
and raise a ton of money you know
there's a lot of equity out there yeah
like you know like from going to Expo
like is a lot as a business if of like
you know healthy natural food like
there's a lot of money floating around
out there I'm sure had you wanted to you
could have gone and raised massive
amounts of capital yeah but to keep it
like you know contained in that way
yeah we're I'm very proud of that and I
think that's a combination of you know
direction and then also limited time
where I'm just like I'm not gonna get
somebody behind this thing while I'm
doing it 20 hours a week one racing you
know training 20 to 30 hours a week and
now as I evaluate you know as I'm
spending more kind of full time in the
business and I evaluate options now it's
like the I think there is some
legitimate benefit to me trying to
achieve that vision by getting some
appropriate partners behind it but the
key question is gonna be to those people
aligned with that vision or are they
okay yeah I'll help you accelerate the
business but then we want Alex that we
want out in three to four years and then
and then it's then it just chopped up
and going this route you know yeah
exactly so it's kind of fun it's finding
people that are like yeah we're we're
excited about what you're trying to do
here and we're excited about the impact
they can have on the community and those
types of things so ultimately that's
what I'm looking for now but we'll you
know we'll see if we don't you know I
don't know I mean it could just be that
we keep doing it ourselves I mean we've
made some we've made some really great
gains just even in the last six or seven
months that I've been working on it
full-time and you know so I'm gonna at
least give myself a year of doing it
full-time of you Alex
it's just crazy like to listen to you is
like let's just take a moment and
reflect on the fact that you've built
this thing and got it to where it's at
now by essentially being a part-time CEO
yeah
like what happens when you when you
attune your full attention hopefully
good hopefully good things you know it's
like I was mentioning before I feel like
you know to certain extent for every
problem I solve I'm kind of like
uncovering another couple that I didn't
know existed but that's what job is see
that's my job is solving problems yeah
like getting to a day where there are no
that's all right you'll never come it's
very it's exciting for me it's a it's
like an athletic journey it's it's
having this big goal and you know I'm
feeling very personally fulfilled to see
it like you know come to realization
there's all the same data involved you
know like instead of looking right back
on my Strava splits like I'm pulling out
my Shopify app and I got our say hell
yeah for the day like how many new club
members do we get you know like all that
you know so there's a lot of if there's
a ton if I that somehow there likely is
entrepreneurs I mean I I look at those
apps all the time you know and it's the
same obsession I had with my with my you
know splits or data before and so it but
it but it's fun you know and and i do
you know i do legitimately enjoy the the
the legitimate positive feedback we get
back from people you know like when we
when we launched that that i love carbs
campaign you know with the t-shirts
people really they really that really
galvanized some people that made them
feel good you know they're like kind of
felt like they were losing their voice
and the in some of the you know
craziness of some of the diet trends
that go on and and so it's it's cool to
you know I guess like simultaneously
just just mean something to people as
well you know and and that that's yeah
that's been really do it in a fun way
and do it in a fun way
yeah totally we're never taking
ourselves too seriously so yeah yeah how
has other than like bonding you with
your wife like how is this podcast or
anything for you doing it for a while
now right like how many episodes you
guys have I know it's pretty funny I
gotta tell a little story about rich
because I I call I I called you maybe
like a year ago and was like hey long
ago I think
I mean maybe maybe nine months you know
ten ten months but I was like hey I
think you know I'm thinking about doing
something creating some type of content
thing and you know maybe writing maybe
doing whatever and I kind of I feel like
I remember you saying something like
well I wouldn't start a podcast no I
don't think I said that I probably said
something like like it's getting crowded
and if you're gonna do it you should
have like an interesting unique Idol and
that's a little bit different from
writing to sit down and interview people
yeah totally and I guess like and so
I'll qualify that was saying in no way
shape or form were you at all
being like like at all pushing back on
anything that I was trying to do you you
or I should actually say we're also
thank you very much for the incredible
support that you have given Lauren and I
with your expertise first book writing
and everything else so so we but but
yeah we did ultimately we did end up
doing a podcast and and it has been it
has been really fun you know like it's
it's small you know it's it's not
anything you know anywhere in the realm
of what you're doing here but it's it's
not that though it's fun yeah it's fun
and it's and it's here's the thing I
think it's it's legitimately fun and
valuable time for Lauren and I which is
cool it justifies our time and if you're
having fun doing it and it's it's adding
value to your life outside of any
external parties then that's already
even if it even if it's just going in to
exploit one person yeah exactly yeah
so and then and then we're getting you
know we get a lot of positive feedback
from the content too which is really
great I think the thing that's gonna be
tough for us with the the the platform
that we've created where we're answering
people's questions is versus like
interviewing people is how does it not
become repetitive however how are you
how is there enough variation in the
questions that you're not you're always
gonna be recycling like certain themes
but you're but it doesn't become like Oh
what comes back to those magnet on your
mom's refer yeah yeah yeah like you just
keep doing it yeah and it'll it'll tell
you what it wants to
yeah you'll and exactly know what those
moves are yeah so but we're really
enjoying it you know I mean it's still
like I said still very very small but
but we really like it
you know it's yeah it's been really fun
it's it's just a cool reason for Lauren
90 kid across from a tables each other
and just give each other [ __ ] you know
talk about you know people's stuff and
then talk talk about the last week in
our own lives and reflect on it you know
there's a there's a you know a thirst
for just anything real yeah I mean it's
like I think if I could if I would say
anything you it's just like don't worry
about like how you're lacing it with
some valuable takeaway just the shears
talk just just you guys having a real
conversation in and of itself is like is
the wind right and then people will
automatically extract from that you know
something that's good advice
yeah that's that's good advice we got to
wrap this up yeah I want to do before we
do that I want to I want to talk to you
about like this and you just announced
that you're gonna be doing a marathon oh
yeah I did yeah this is new yeah this
have you ever run like a formal no
marathon well I've run a 244 after a
swim in a buy a magic but like um no yes
so this was a I was actually really
nervous about making that public and
that just happened a couple few days and
go on on Instagram you know just because
you know I've even though I built myself
up as a as a as an athlete in the space
that is pursuing all different kinds of
challenges like this was a big big
departure for me too for me to actively
say hey and and what I actively said was
hey I I need to spend more time in my
business and more time on my family
therefore I just don't feel like I can
train adequately for even a half ironman
certainly not an Ironman and I kind of
have given myself a training budget of
about ten hours a week it's about as
that's as much time as I feel
comfortable allocating the training
and because of that how do I want to
pivot my goals is there's still some
cool athletic goal that I could try to
go accomplish that would still be the
best I've personally ever done that fits
within that time constraint and that was
a marathon to me that was like I started
running a little bit more as like man I
you know I only ran 30 miles a week as a
triathlete my entire career anyway and
so can I take some of these things that
I've learned some of this extra aerobic
capacity but then also some of these
things that I'm so much better at now
than I was I'm clearly not the same
runner I was when I was 23 I am 39 but
I've learned so much more can I apply
that being able to go off a feel better
having much better nutrition like
nutritional habits and can I see what I
can get on myself and and I am supremely
lucky in that I have sponsors like we
the guys we talked about roca my own
company
desaad diamond and and and redbull who
said yeah we're cool with you doing that
and if you go tell a story like that's
super unique will you come from from an
industry that's like we want you to do
Kona or nothing right a guy comes in
it's like I want to go run a marginally
fast marathon that's not going to be
competitive on like a national level at
all but it's just gonna be like hey what
can I do right and maybe plan I'm not
gonna win and there's not going to be
with my other job I'm gonna train 10
hours a week but I'm gonna tell the
story about it and I think people will
be interested in it and they were
supportive which is really cool I think
so what you're gonna find is is first of
all it's very smart and forward-thinking
of these sponsors to get on board with
that because what you're gonna find is
by telling that story in real time as
you progress towards it
it is so much more accessible to the
average person than like hey I'm gonna
go to Roth and try to win yeah totally
it can't you're like well that's
inspiration yeah I can't really connect
with that but hey ten hours a week
because he's got kids and he's got a
business I relate to that yeah you know
but the most I have is two
six hours a week so I can get on board
with this and you're gonna go and you're
gonna kick ass and you have this amazing
result you're not gonna win but you're
gonna you're gonna run a fast time and I
think that's going to be a source of a
tremendous amount of inspiration and an
emotional connection with the people
that are following you which ultimately
is much more valuable than definitely
some triathlete you've never heard of at
an ITU race that is on a podium when I
was getting sponsored by whoever helps
them and I think that that bodes well
for the future of what these corporate
sponsor relationships look like for
athletes because it goes back to how we
started this conversation it's about
storytelling and it totally tell a story
well and and and have it create value
for that brand that's taking a shot on
you then that's really you know that's
really how you can deliver the most
value to those people that have been
with you and have believed absolutely a
long time yeah and it's and it's it's
infinitely more fun for me yeah you know
is the other part of it there's not much
pressure no that's the thing I don't I
want to do well because I'm you know cuz
I'm competitive and I want to get the
most out of myself but it's not you know
it's not the same as what I was doing
before and but it's also like you know
it's just like I said it's it's a lot
more fun you know I mean the triathlon
you know that's hard to I mean it's a
grind my body is you know wearing down
and and so this just allows me to spend
more time with my family and do all
those things I talked about while also
doing something that's unique and and
then eventually after I do that the
marathon maybe there will be some other
cool challenge down the road that fits
within those realms too and you know
they swim run oh man
somebody told me I'd sure try to do that
with you yeah you know I do all I go do
swim run so soon he said that cuz I
honestly was like looking at races or
something and somebody suggested that I
can't remember that but that would be
way too much of a mismatch because like
I can't there's no way I could keep up
with you and then there's no way I'd
keep up with you on this swim either
that the thing with the swim run for me
is that you have to swim which is kind
of a bummer yeah you do have to swim but
you actually don't get to run that much
is that really
climbing over rocks now alright I mean
it's obviously completely course
dependent I mean it looks cool I mean it
was fun
yeah it looks like an awesome experience
I mean and that's ultimately like I just
like you're glad for now there's this
whole thing and there's all these races
popping up yeah
mostly in Europe I mean I already hear a
little bit yeah like this guy large
vinegars you know Chris yeah I know
series yeah and I think that's exciting
and fun to just see the evolution of
multi-sport and you know and different
stuff yeah I think so too
I think is I think you know going back
to a little bit what we talk about with
WTC and Iron Man and kind of the
monopolization around that I think
there's gonna be more and more appetite
for less you know just just different
multi-sport events that that aren't the
kind of cut and dry half Iron Man Iron
Man you know SuperDuper competitive you
know whatever and we've you I've even
got I've got some ideas for events I've
loved it I'd love to have it bend that
you know are just kind of off the crazy
you know weird multi-sport stuff that
combines a whole bunch of stuff you know
there's not one there's a one invent
called pull pedalpaddle which is a super
yeah yeah yeah yes did you do that I did
that yeah yeah yeah so that's like super
fun then just be fun to find some more
stuff like that yeah just don't call it
a retirement no yeah I know yeah exactly
our transition I know that's right
that's what I'm saying I said in that
post I was like I'm not retiring I'm
also not trying to make the Olympic team
right now it's just I'm just gonna go
run a marathon there's a dude that's
running a marathon see how it goes
cool so yeah but you haven't announced
which one yet you know I think Eugene I
think it's gonna be Eugene yeah I looked
at Boston which is a couple weeks before
and I actually reached out to them and
then I didn't hear back right away and
then like over the week or so that I was
kind of waiting to hear back from them I
kind of was like I don't really know if
I want to do Boston and the reason was
getting my family all the way out there
and everything it just seemed like more
you know it goes back to like just a
little bit more than I'd want to like
put into it Eugene is doing it for fun
doing it for fun it's like a sure
release as opposed to going into a
pressure cooker totally yeah I can have
my family their piggy bars will be there
you know it's like just over the
mountains from us it's a great course
it's a it's where we started picky bars
you know so it's kind of cool to go back
there and there's storytelling yeah
that's the thing yeah it's it's cool
it'll be so that'll be fun so yeah all
right man we'll come back nique tell me
about it after you do it all right yeah
absolutely and bring Lauren there yeah
yeah will do really appreciate it rich
thanks so much
yeah thank you super fun if you're
diggin on Jesse you can he's pretty easy
to find yeah Jesse Thomas
yeah and instagrams probably the best
place yeah Jesse M Thomas Jesse M Thomas
yes right and picky bars calm yep picky
bars calm or at picky bars on social so
yeah we're all out there yeah I
appreciate it awesome man yeah thanks
dude awesome yeah
[Music]